pour olive oil into a hot pan add  chopped tomatoes  spring onions and fry season next add  cooked prawns and a sprinkle of chili  flakes to give it a lovely kick of heat  cook through and set aside next beat  four eggs add olive oil to your frying  pan and pour in the eggs  sprinkled on freshly chopped oregano  which works brilliantly with eggs and  spoon over the spicy prawns crumpled  over creamy feta cheese and grill for a  couple of minutes  this is eggs to the nth degree  packed with different tastes textures  and flavors all working wonderfully  together perfect next add fresh chopped  tomatoes then cumin seeds and fry until  the seeds are fragrant and the tomatoes  are lovely and soft and then for extra  richness knobs of butter then butter a  baking dish and pour in your rich cheesy  cheats soufflé mix